I am always interested in hearing about
the evolution of a film so what would
you say is the biggest difference
between how you pictured ironclaw first
turning out when you first said to
yourself I'm going to make this movie
and now what everyone's going to see in
the finished future well the challenge
with this was that when you know I first
decided to explore them and and did the
research and kind of laid out the family
history and everything I could find
about them what I was looking at was a
epic Greek tragedy you know and it's uh
mythical in in the in proportion of what
happened to them what they went through
just the wrestling world the highs and
the lows and so the challenge for me was
starting with something so large how do
you fit that into a film and and I wrote
the script for seven years so it was a
you know a process of chipping away and
finding the core and ultimately you know
Kevin and speaking speaking with Kevin
and hearing what he the way he speaks
and how open he is and and how he's sort
of risen from everything that he went
through and the family went through his
the story of his survival became the
core and therefore um you know the focus
of the film The Heart the Beating Heart
of this film is really something else
I'll go I'll go from there to to
authenticity in a movie because I'm
always fascinated to hear about finding
that balance between authenticity and
creative license when you're adapting
someone's true story so can you pinpoint
something everyone will see in the movie
that you knew it was the utmost
importance to hold tight to and get
right but then also something else where
it was better to take creative license
to best serve the film yeah
um yeah it's a great question I mean you
know there there are there are things
that that I I I heard uh I I read that
someone said or heard this you know so
when you know Kevin says uh I am S I
used to be a brother and I'm not a
brother anymore that is something I've
heard Kevin say you know uh fr Fritz
saying um you know at the funeral like
take off those glasses like we're not
going to show any tears today those are
you know those are things that I heard
him say so there are these these
emotional pillars that are directly from
that but then you know there's uh you
know you can't be inside a first date or
a dinner conversation so there's things
as a writer personally that you know you
have to imagine or bring in your own
personal things to to fill fill those
SCS that date is such a good scene I
love how she drives that scene with such
Authority yeah she's a great character
one thing I always love about all of
your films is the casting is absolutely
exceptional I'll try to squeeze in two
questions about that first of all the
main roles in this movie which was the
easiest to fill where the right person
just like magically came to you but then
also what was the most difficult role to
cast where finding the perfect fit for
that character took you know some real
leg work to find the right actor so I
would say the first person who was just
a clear fit was was halt malleny for
Fritz I mean I saw him on mind Hunter
and he was probably the first person I
was like he has to be Fritz that's it um
so that was uh that was the first part
and then um you know the the rest I I
would say in some ways the only you know
uh casting Stanley uh as Mike you know
that was a casting process that was we
were looking for a discovery there
trying to find someone who hadn't done
anything or much before and so we really
wanted to have a a a you know disc
Discovery in in that role so it was just
a bit more digging but once we saw him
it was just clear that he was the one so
so perfect so going from from Lizzy uh
Carrie comes to mind now Zach it
makes me wonder what is something you
look for in a lead actor when casting
that role that signals to you this
person won't just nail the character I'm
about to hand them but they're also
going to be a good collaborator for the
for me and the team I surround myself
with yeah just conversation you know
just you sit and you talk to someone and
you sort of know immediately energy-wise
how they
communicate um and and how they're going
to fit in and and and look so much of
what we do is directing as Instinct like
I I just operate so much on Instinct and
and just getting a feeling and following
it and um yeah so it can you give me an
example of when that instinct came into
play Big Time on set where your approach
to a particular scene shifted in the
moment because your instinct told you to
roll with something that was happening
that you didn't plan for oh great
question um
um yeah I think I think in the wrestling
I think because we had a very short prep
time and the guys really trained and
they learned how to wrestle and we
choreograph the matches but also you
can't perfectly choreograph the matches
with the camera moves for instance
because and we're trying to shoot full
matches from top to bottom and so there
would be you know on the day you'd have
very limited time because you can only
do it so many times as well so it's like
you do a match once and you'd see
something happening and maybe you'd you
know we would make a quick choice to
change uh you know it was was basically
both shooting something that had been
scripted and choreographed but also live
performance and so it was really moving
to always try and find the emotion or or
the best way to tap into Kevin's
experience